Hello I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
Today I Found Out YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at why book
copyright pages often have the numbers 1-10
written on them
The number line, or printer's key, often seen
on the copyright page of books is simply a
method of record-keeping that helps identify
the book's printing and, for some, year of
printing a specific book, which may or may
not be different than the original copyright
date listed elsewhere on the page.
Common examples of these number lines are
as follows:
While different publishers use different conventions
for these number lines, generally speaking,
the smallest number in the line indicates
a books printing.
So if 1 through 10 is at the bottom of the
page, it is a first printing; if the number
one has been removed, so the number line is
2 through 10, it is a second printing; and
so on.
The reason they remove a number each time
instead of, say, just changing one number
has to do with the way publishers have historically
printed books.
For instance, in offset printing, you can
relatively easily remove something from the
printing plate, but adding a number would
require creating a whole new plate.
You might have also noticed sometimes number
lines are accompanied by the words First edition
but that does not necessarily mean it is the
first printing; for example, the numbers 3
through 10 accompanied by the text First Edition
would indicate the third printing of the first
edition.
There may be many printings of an edition,
the latter of which may be defined as a single
"setting-up of type without substantial change."
So, if the author doesn't change the text
of the book (like text books authors frequently
do), and the pages all stay the same, then
if the publisher simply makes another round
of copies, it isn't a new edition, it's just
a new printing.
If, however, the pages are substantially modified,
or the book is reformatted, such as for printing
in paperback, then the printings in this new
format will be a new edition.
Note, though, that it may not be designated
as a second edition (or third or fourth),
and instead may be called a first paperback
edition, first US edition or Penguin Classics
first edition.
Serious collectors typically consider these
last inferior to the cherished first edition,
first printing.
Depending on the publisher, the number line
might also indicate the year the printing
was done, as follows.
This reveals that this second printing was
done in 1990.
Much like with the print run numbers, if the
book is printed again the following year,
the 90 would be removed, leaving the year
part of the string as 93 92 91.
Moreover, if the publisher contracts with
an outside company to do the printing, that
company may be indicated in the number line
as well; in this example, the number line
shows Melissa's Printing Company was hired
to do a third printing in 2016.
In addition, some publishers prefer other
kinds of lines; for example, Anness Publishing
uses a number line that alternates its digits
as follows, and a second or fifth printing
from this publishing company would look like
this.
This particular schema is used to keep the
number line relatively centered over multiple
print runs.
Further demonstrating the lack of standardization
across publishers for the printer's key, the
publishing giant Random House has indicated
its first edition, first printing with the
words first edition but with a number line
that begins with 2 as follows; however, it
uses this same number, just without the words
first edition, to indicate a second printing.
So I hoped you enjoyed this video, if you
did please do give it a like below and consider
sharing it with anyone you think might also
enjoy it.
It really helps us out a lot.
And if you’re at all interested in supporting
our efforts monetarily check out our patreon
page linked below.
We’ve got some good perks there, including
perhaps the most requested thing on this channel-
a video of Simon Whistler whistling.
Thanks for watching.